Ja, ich höre dich nicht. Okay, ist das immer noch so, Mario?
Ah, jetzt ist gut, dann, ich glaube.
Ah, okay, gut, super.
Ja, jetzt hört ich, ja, jetzt ist gut.
Wunderbar, gut, sind jetzt so ziemlich alle da.
Ich würde einfach starten, wie gesagt, ich nehme das auf und ihr könnt es dann auch,
falls ihr irgendwas verpasst habt, im Nachhinein dann nochmal auf der Homepage anschauen.
Ich glaube, der Nikolaus fehlt noch, aber ich starte jetzt, na, iPhone vielleicht.
Gut, ich starte jetzt einfach weiter, mach weiter.
Wie gesagt, ich habe ja nur begrenzt Zeit, deshalb würde ich gerne weitergehen.
Und mache gerade mit Metro-Paraport weiter.
Wie gesagt, wir haben da die Temperaturkurve und die Tauchungskurve für die Thermik.
Grün ist für uns nutzbar, schwarz ist zu stabil und rot wäre sehr stark, aber auch noch gut für uns.
Also einfach sehr, sehr stark.
Mit dazu haben wir rechts genau nochmal den Wind mit Richtung und Stärke.
Es hat da sogar die Höhe der Thermik.
Auch da hat man sogar, wenn es Niederschlag gibt, wird der auch noch angezeigt.
Also reicht, oder man hat eigentlich alle.
Alle Inputs, wo man braucht als ganz normaler Pilot.
Und auch das natürlich dort unten mit weiter im Voraus.
Also deutlich besser noch von der Planung her, wo man noch ein bisschen weiter gehen kann und schauen kann.
Und eigentlich wie beim anderen Immagramm auch, sobald sich die zwei Kurven berühren,
gibt es da oder so Wolkenbildung, unabhängig von der thermischen Entwicklung.
Eigentlich sehr, sehr gut sichtbar.
Ja.
Das ist eigentlich schon alles für Meteo Parapo.
Es ist simpel, es ist gut strukturiert und aus meiner Sicht auch hilfreich.
Dann die Technik, die ich nutze, tatsächlich nicht extrem viel.
Es gibt einfach ein paar Sachen, wo ich bei Burn eher recht gut finde.
Es gibt auch ein paar Sachen, wo ich denke, es ist jetzt ein bisschen, ja braucht wie nicht.
Und manchmal sogar, aus meiner Sicht, ein bisschen zu unübersichtlich.
Durch die Fülle an Informationen, denke ich, macht es das manchmal auch ein bisschen zu unübersichtlich.
Aber es ist schon ganz cool, was es da alles zu bieten hat.
Proben, man kann da auswählen, welche Map das eröffnen wollte.
Burn eher Map, da sind da Startplätze und so weiter.
Und dann kann man da herauslesen.
Auch das sehr gut.
Und Talwinde herauslesen.
Es kommt immer darauf an, was ihr da gelöst habt, was freigeschalten ist oder nicht.
Was könnt ihr da auswählen?
Wenn wir jetzt mal rein auf die Weltprognose, was hier für uns wichtig ist, gehen,
dann wird es dann gleich einmal doch wieder ein bisschen unübersichtlich.
Ihr habt dann die siebente Reize zur Auswahl,
mit dem ihr wählen könnt.
Also wenn euch Wolken und Niederschlag mal am Anfang das Ganze eher unübersichtlich gestalten,
so wie das jetzt der Fall ist, dann könnt ihr das ganz einfach oben links ausstellen.
Dann habt ihr das schon mal weg.
Und dann habt ihr da links die Höhe für den jeweiligen Wind.
50 Meter über Grund, 250 Meter über Grund, was ich gar nicht so schlecht finde.
Die eigenen Höhen, die man durchspielen kann, mit unten die Tage,
mit den Aktien, was ich eigentlich sehr lässig finde,
wo man dann ein bisschen weiter in die Zukunft schauen kann.
Und dann habt ihr, das ist eben noch ganz wichtig, da rechts extrem viele Möglichkeiten zur Auswahl.
Zum einen könnt ihr da mal die verschiedensten Hintergründe wählen.
Also ihr könnt da zum Beispiel Satellit Google einwählen,
dann habt ihr da die Satelliteneinblendung.
Und ihr könnt Google eingeben.
Also ihr könnt euch ein bisschen durchspielen.
Da könnt ihr schauen, was ist für euch die Unterlegung, wo es für euch am übersichtlichsten macht.
Ich finde Turnair-Topo gar nicht so verkehrt, weil ich brauche nicht zu viel Schnörkel drumherum.
Und dann könnt ihr mal eine Zeit lang mitarbeiten.
Dann habt ihr da rechts wirklich wahnsinnig viel Auswahl.
Und das ist halt dann immer abhängig, was ihr zuschalten könnt.
Aber was ich jetzt ganz cool finde, das seht ihr da schon eingeblendet,
sind bei mir so die Live-Druckwerte.
Müssen wir selber schauen, wo das ist.
Meteo-Live-Differenzen, Druck-Differenzen.
Das sind Sachen, die bei mir jetzt schon mal mit eingeblendet sind.
Live-Windwerte kann man mit einblenden.
Also man kann da sehr, sehr viel einstellen.
Wie gesagt.
Manchmal wird es dann aber auch ein bisschen zu unübersichtlich kommen.
Könnt ihr, wenn ihr zu viel eingestellt habt, alle wieder ausstellen.
Und danach nach und nach reinholen, was ihr wollt, was ihr braucht.
Auch da finde ich eigentlich sehr cool, wenn man am Anfang mal ein bisschen weiter rauszoomt.
Und sich das Ganze von weiter draußen her anschaut.
Wo hat es wirklich Gebiete mit sehr, sehr starkem Wind?
Und wo ist man vielleicht?
Eine Nuance geschützter, oder?
Und kann das Ganze mit den verschiedenen Höhen auch da dann durchspielen.
1.000 und hier gerade bei 1.500 und 2.000 Metern sieht man dann hervorragend.
Das ist jetzt sehr gut.
Auch bei Wind ist es sehr gut.
Aber hier vielleicht einfach noch ein bisschen besser.
Aber aus meiner Sicht klarer dargestellt mit den Farben noch diese Auslöse bei Höhen.
Das ist besser erkennbar.
Also das muss man dem Bernie neidlos zugestehen.
Das hat er sehr gut gemacht.
Man kann wirklich sehr gut so Abflüsse, gerade bei Höhenlagen, erkennen.
Wenn wir jetzt auf 2.000 Meter gehen, wird es noch besser ersichtlich.
Und das finde ich schon, muss ich sagen, auch wiederum von der Darstellung her sehr gut.
Also das muss man ihm lassen.
Das hat er sehr gut gemacht.
Wenn man jetzt...
Ah, no.
Wenn ich da noch ein bisschen genauer reinblicken möchte,
dann habe ich hier sogar noch die Previtems mit eingeblendet.
Wenn ich da aufblicke, öffnet sich dort unten...
Ich muss schauen, dass das nicht zufällig zusammenbricht.
Öffnet sich dort unten.
In muss ich jetzt ehrlich gestehen, finde ich ein bisschen unübersichtlicher.
Also es ist nicht ganz so einfach herauszulesen, wo hat es...
Vielleicht eine eher stabilere Schichtung drinnen.
Also man kann es gut herauslesen, aber ich finde es einfach so von der Optik her,
finde ich das jetzt bei Meteo Parapor besser gelöst.
Aber auch hier sieht man halt den Wind in verschiedenen Höhen dargestellt,
mit dem feinen Richtung und die Stärke, auch dort unten dann so der Mittelwert
für die jeweilige Höhe.
Man hat da noch die Badeshöhe mit drinnen.
Eigentlich auch da wieder sehr, sehr...
Viel Informationen.
Ganz oben hat man die Wolkenmenge bzw. im Stockwerk, dass die angesiedelt sind.
Hier sieht man, dass sogar noch ein bisschen Niederschlag aufkommt.
Also auch da kann man sich wirklich sehr viel Infos rausholen.
Was ich jetzt sehr gut finde an dem Ganzen,
ist, dass man hier mit der Temperatur sehr schnell sieht,
wie hoch ist die tatsächlich in der Höhe.
Also zum Beispiel, wir waren 2023 im Tessin,
und es war wirklich arschkalt.
Auf 2.000, 2.500 Metern hat es wirklich minus 8, minus 10 Grad gehabt.
Auf 2.500 waren es dann, ich glaube, schon minus 15 Grad.
Und das hat man da herauslesen können.
Und dann war man auch wirklich in der Luft, sehr schnell zu froh.
Und das sieht man auch hier.
Minus 6,1 Grad.
Die Temperatur herrscht, also sehr kalt ist.
Und die warmen, stabilen Flüchten sind da mit Rot gekennzeichnet.
Man sieht das schon auch gut.
Ich finde halt einfach, die Fülle an Informationen macht für mich ein bisschen unübersichtlicher.
Aber an und für sich, auch da kann man sehr viel herauslesen.
Jetzt meines Wissens nur mit dem entsprechenden Abo.
Wie gesagt, das...
Für euch ist eigentlich der Wind wichtig.
Und auch hier könnt ihr mit dem Wind wirklich in den verschiedenen Höhen spielen.
Weil ich finde halt nur noch cool, sind die Live-Druckdifferenzen zwischen Nord und Süd.
Und vor allen Dingen ein bisschen besser aufgegeilt.
Das heißt, verschiedenste auch ein bisschen mehr in die Richtung.
Also das ist für mich da schon eine ordentliche Information, die da vorhanden ist.
Und mit dem kann man sich auch sehr gut vorbereiten.
Eine allgemeine Prognose, müsst ihr immer schauen.
Ich würde Maximum drei solche Apps benutzen.
Und dann versuchen herauszufinden, welche für euch vor denen dann noch die zuverlässigste ist.
Und dann vielleicht mit nur zwei sogar arbeiten.
Aber Maximum drei, hätte ich gesagt.
Und das ist halt auch immer gut im Vergleich zu haben.
Dann sieht man sehr, sehr schnell, mit welchem man an deinem Ort gut arbeiten kann.
Wie gesagt, man hat immer die Möglichkeit, den Niederschlag und die Wolken einzublenden.
Und da müsst ihr einfach drauf schauen.
Sobald da ein grafierter Markier ist, dann heißt es, die Wolken berühren da das Gelände.
Also das Detail hier ist alles Wolkenverhalten.
Wolkenverhangen, Wolkenverhangen.
Das sind wiederum sehr, sehr gut gemacht.
Und Niederschlagbereiche werden dann logischerweise hier mit Blau-Grün angezeigt.
Also hier einen ordentlichen Niederschlag.
Und so kann man dann auch noch Wolkenmenge, Wolkenhöhe sogar herauslesen und den Niederschlag.
Das finde ich eigentlich sehr gut gemacht.
Wie gesagt, ihr könnt schauen, es gibt.
Vom Bernie gibt es da jenseits Erklärungen.
Man kann extrem viel mit seinem App herauslesen.
Ich würde es aufs Minimum für euch reduzieren.
Weil auch da habe ich jetzt die Erfahrung gemacht, dass die Prognose,
es nimmt zwar das Icon-Modell, aber ich finde, die Prognose ist eher auf der deutlich pessimistischeren Seite.
Nur mit Burner arbeiten heißt für mich auch wirklich deutlich weniger fliegen und was nicht grundsätzlich verkehrt ist.
Aber wenn man das weiß, dann kann man da auch vielleicht noch ein anderes App mit dazunehmen.
Und dann hat man vielleicht doch deutlich mehr Flugtage.
Also wenn man sich nur mit Burner vorbereitet, ist meine Ansicht nach ein bisschen zu pessimistisch.
Aber zusätzlich Informationsquelle.
Finde ich extrem wichtig und gut.
Wer da noch kein Abo gelöst hat, ihr könnt das euch nachher noch in den Chat reinsetzen.
Ihr könnt da 10 Franken sparen mit einem Gutschein-Code von mir und auf das jeweilige Abo und euch so noch mal ein bisschen was einsparen.
Aber auch hier auszoomen, reindoomen wirklich sehr gut möglich und macht halt wirklich visuell sichtbar,
wo hat es mehr Wind, wo hat es vielleicht Bereiche mit weniger Wind, wo kann ich eher fliegen gehen.
Und was halt hier sehr, sehr gut dargestellt ist, hier sieht man wirklich sehr schnell mit 1.500 und 2.000 Metern Höhen
und macht visuell wirklich gut sichtbar.
Und das finde ich gerade jetzt für den heutigen beziehungsweise morgigen Tag, wo sehr, sehr viel Höhen gemeldet ist, ja, finde ich das sehr gut.
Und es funktioniert.
Funktioniert auch bei schwacheren Höhen sehr gut.
Also das ist meine Erfahrung, finde ich sehr gelungen vor der Darstellung.
Gut, das ist so Wind, Wolken, Niederschlag.
Mit denen drei Apps kann man sich da eigentlich sehr gut durcharbeiten.
Ihr solltet euch immer auch den Bodenbruck anschauen.
Ihr habt das ja bei mir auf dem App sowieso.
Da habt ihr jeweils die Messung und die Prognose vom Meteor Schweiz.
Die ist gerade übereinander liegend, was auch sehr gut ist.
Wer aber noch ein bisschen weiter vorausschauen möchte, haben wir ja gesehen, kann man mit Windy und den Isobaren machen.
Aber vom Deutschen Wetterdienst, gibt es auch diese die Prognosenkarte, die wird früher vom Wetterdienst erstellt.
Aber dort hat man auf der Seite selbst, hat man die Möglichkeit.
Da natürlich.
In die.
Zukunft zu blicken und sieht dann halt trotzdem noch
nicht nur Isobaren, sondern eben auch die dazugehörigen
Kunden. Das ist eigentlich auch noch
für mich, für meine Vorbereitung wichtig. Da kann ich
wirklich bis zu 108 Stunden in die Zukunft blicken und
sehe halt gleich, sind wir eher im Hochdruckeinfluss oder
näher im Tiefdruckeinfluss, wenn wir da mal weiter
auf den Samstag hingehen.
Samstag ist dann so der Übergangstag. Der Sonntag sieht, glaube ich, nicht so
schlecht aus, aber halt ziemlich starke Wiese. Genau, kann man
da eigentlich sehen, was uns betrifft.
Hingegen, wenn wir sagen, was in der Analyse der Fall ist,
da sind wir voll im Tiefdruckeinfluss, da im
sogenannten Farmsektor. Bischen den einzelnen Fronten
hängen wir da quasi fest.
Und das fände ich eigentlich nur eine sehr coole Variante, um
deutlich weiter in die Zukunft zu blicken, was jetzt
die Bodendruckverteilung angeht und die Großwetterlage.
Da müsst ihr halt beim deutschen Wettbewerbsdienst
schauen unter Daten, Anleitungen
und Analyse und Prognosen.
Ich kann euch da den Link direkt in WhatsApp
rein.
Falls ihr euch den abspeichern wollt, finde ich eigentlich ganz cool
und ist eine sehr gute Vorbereitung. Wie gesagt, die
Analyse sowie die Vorherberechnung von
Meteo Schweiz, wo ja auf dem Handy
hat das ja mittlerweile jeder Schweizer,
die Vorherberechnung der Bodendruckkarte
geht dann immer für 13 Uhr Lokalzeit.
Das könnt ihr dann immer sehr, sehr gut
miteinander vergleichen.
Das gehört für mich eigentlich auch zur Vorbereitung dazu.
Noch diejenigen, die angemeldet sind beim
Meteobereich, der auch sehr viele Informationen bietet,
unter anderem noch einmal ein anderes Winddiagramm,
also anders in dem Bezug, das eine andere Skalierung hat.
Vom Tag her ist es nochmal ein bisschen besser.
Aber sicherlich, ja, ob man da jetzt am Nachmittag noch fliegen kann oder nicht.
Was ich nicht ganz so gut finde, ist einfach die Grenze von fünf
Hektar Pascal hat ja doch oft gezeigt, dass vier tatsächlich ab vier
ist es dann wirklich merklich stark geworden.
Und drum denke ich, ist vier nach wie vor noch so eine Grenze,
wo man nicht drüber gehen sollte.
Aus meiner Sicht.
Drum finde ich die Grenze mit fünf nicht ganz so glücklich.
Was aber ein bisschen besser darstellt, ist Süden ist dort unten und Norden ist dort oben.
Da kommt die Realität schon ein bisschen näher.
Möchte ich euch sagen, ich habe da oder es gibt da ebenfalls vom deutschen Wetterdienst,
da sprechen auch noch verschiedene Diagramme.
Ihr habt da im linken Bereich auch noch Wiederschlag.
Ihr habt Wolken, wo wir abrufen.
Könnt und was da ganz cool ist, ist eigentlich Sonnenschein, Dauer,
auch wenn wir da mal kurz draufgehen.
Nein, das ist nicht das, was ich wollte.
Machen wir das unter die Report der Möglichkeit,
woran abrufen könnt und dann habt ihr unterhalb von der Niederschlag
Karte da die Sonnenschein, Dauer, da kann man eben so genannte
Bühnenfenster auch sehr, sehr gut erkennen.
Ja,
da dann auf den morgigen Tag gehen, dann sieht man da das Bühnenfenster,
was dann gegen Abend hin abgebaut wird.
Also zum Beispiel auch nur etwas, was ihr sehr, sehr gut nutzen könnt.
Beim SRV wird ein Gewunschlecht aufgebaut.
Das Modell ist jetzt gewechselt.
Nicht mehr das Cosmo Modell, sondern das Icon Modell.
Von dem her muss man da jetzt schauen.
Sind die Prognosen sicher wieder ein bisschen genauer, weil so Wolkenmenge, Niederschlag,
das hat nicht ganz so hingestongoen in der Vergangenheit.
Drum kann man da jetzt mal in der Zukunft schauen, wie sich da die Lage entwickelt.
Da gibt es einen allgemeinen Bereich.
Geht ein bisschen mehr ins Detail.
Die 700 karte beispielsweise sehr gut für umerkennen, wann Fronten reinkommen.
Mal schauen, ob da jetzt.
Vielleicht mal schauen.
Dann können wir da noch etwas nachschauen.
Und dann sehen wir uns da mal wieder, wenn es so weitergeht.
Dann sehen wir uns dann wieder.
Dann sehen wir uns da mal wieder.
schauen, ja, das ist eigentlich schon der
morgige Zack, da sieht man,
wie die restliche Front
da noch reinkommt,
also ich finde es nicht
so schlecht, da fängt es
dann schon an, gibt es schon
gewisse Ausläufer, da ist
dann definitiv der Fall,
also ist auch da nicht
so schlecht für die Vorbereitung,
aber mal noch
auf den deutschen Wetterdienst,
da haben wir
verschiedenste Diagramme, nicht nur
das sogenannte Föhn-Diagramm
und das finde ich eben lästig dort,
man hat dort eben zur Auswahl
auch den Föhn in Österreich,
diese, klar, das haben wir
sowieso, aber eben auch
Wind am Gardasee, hat sehr
gut funktioniert, dann
etwas, was ich in Slowenien
genutzt habe, was
hervorragend funktioniert hat,
war Bora-Diagramm, das
hat mir auch sehr gut geholfen,
dort unten, finde ich also sehr
gut und den Mistfall für Frankreich,
da kann man wirklich
unter verschiedensten Diagrammen
auswählen und
ich finde das halt hervorragend
für die Flugvorbereitung,
da kann man wirklich mit einem
Blick auch sehen, wann passiert
was, wenn wir jetzt bei uns schauen,
sehen wir, dass hier ein starker
Druckabfall vorhanden ist,
das heißt, da irgendwo
kommt dann die Front rein
und auch das ist
eigentlich für die Wettervorbereitung
ja, sehr, sehr wichtig,
aber das hat auch bei mir auf dem App
ja, mit
integriert. Gut,
was vielleicht noch
so ein Zusatzpunkt
Niederschlag und
Wolkenmenge oder
Wolkenradar, das schaue ich
tatsächlich sehr, sehr viel bei
Meteo Schweiz auf dem App,
auf dem Handy, das
funktioniert recht gut, auch da
gibt es hier und da mal
Prognosen, die nicht so
hinkommen, aber Niederschlag,
Prognose finde ich halt da
schon sehr gut
und gehört für mich
dann für den Folgetag
immer mit rein, aber ich denke,
das können die meisten vom App,
vom Handy, also das solltet
ihr auf jeden Fall mit reinnehmen
in eure Prognose.
Gut, dann würde
ich einmal so
eine Windprognose schnell
mit euch durchgehen,
einmal eine Wolkenprognose
mit den
verschiedenen Apps
beziehungsweise nur schnell
mit
Burn Air, Meteo,
PowerPo und Windy
und auch da gibt es dann hier noch
ein sogenanntes Wolkenradar, aber das ist
auf dem Handy besser ersichtlich.
Gut, dann würde ich schnell mit Windy
starten, gerade für den morgigen
Tag.
Wir haben ja nicht mehr so
weit in die Zukunft
blicken müssen, für den morgigen Tag
wechsle ich jetzt hier auf
das Icon D2.
Wir sehen allein schon, ohne dass
ich jetzt die Höhe geändert habe,
aber vom europäischen
Icon D2
zum DWD,
haben wir da
über uns
also schon mal eine ganz andere
Geschwindigkeit.
44 zu 33,
das sind immerhin 11 kmh
und
da müssen wir dann
die jeweilige Höhe anschauen.
Im Moment, im Winter,
empfehle ich euch wirklich
3000er Wind gut anzuschauen.
Der kann gut nach unten
kommen, durchbrechen.
Wir haben noch nicht so
einen Thermikpolster, dass das Ganze
sehr gut abfedern kann oder
besser gesagt, sehr gut nach oben
wegdrückt und deshalb
immer den 3000er Wind sicher
mit reinnehmen. Vielleicht fangt
er sogar erst einmal noch
weiter oben an. 4000er
Wind geht nochmal ein bisschen raus
und erst nachher
wieder in die Tiefe. Also da haben wir
jetzt für morgen auf
4.074 kmh Weltwind
gemeldet um 12 Uhr.
Wir machen jetzt der Einfahrtheit
halber mal nur so um den Mittag rum
und dann wäre wichtig,
dass er morgen auch schaut,
was ist so um den Mittag rum wirklich
für einen Wind vorhanden.
Wir haben gewisse Messstationen,
auch auf 3000 Metern in unserer
Umgebung, wo man abrufen kann und schauen kann,
ist das auch wirklich. Gehen wir da wieder
runter, 4000, gehen wir da mal
jetzt wieder auf 3000 runter.
3000,
wie gesagt, 45 kmh.
Man sieht, dass wir da unten
deutlich weniger
Wind haben, 25
Südwest, also da wäre es vielleicht
sogar auch fliegbar.
Bei Föhn, das ist auch so
luftseitig, könnte man vielleicht
fliegen, wenn es keinen Niederschlag
hat und wenn der Wind trotzdem nicht
zu stark ist. Aber
bei so viel,
weil er hat da unten trotzdem
Stauniederschläge und
nicht so gut fliegbar. Genau.
Das heißt, für uns,
wenn wir da nochmal ein bisschen
runtergehen, der 2000er
Wind passt im Moment
nicht so gut. Aber gehen wir mal
da runter, dann haben wir
20 kmh,
wo man wirklich auch unsere
20 kmh könnte
in etwa
hinkommen morgen.
Unsere Station ist
ja auf 2150 Meter
oder so. Ganz genau kann ich
euch nicht sagen, aber da könnte man dann
morgen schauen, was da an sich
am Startlöchern ist.
Meistens ist es eben so, dass der Südwestwind
am Grafen schon selber gar nicht richtig
ankommt, sondern mehr als West-Nordwestwind.
Aber schauen wir morgen mal,
ob da auf 2000 Meter
zwischen uns landen kann.
Dann können wir vielleicht,
ich habe noch 10 Minuten Zeit,
dann gehen wir gerade auf
den Metroparabol, schauen,
was sagen Sie.
Da muss man dann natürlich den
Bereich noch auswählen, nehmen wir
unseren Bereich, Donnerstag,
da unten die Anträge brauchen wir nicht wechseln,
wir sind ja hier,
12 Uhr auf 2000
Meter, die sind sich
zwar
einig, wir haben dort
auch
um die 20 kmh
Wind südwestlicher
Richtung und dann wird
eigentlich da ab 13 Uhr
sehr stark, dann können wir gerade
schnell
auf dem Handy
und schauen, ob es um 13 Uhr
dort auch startet.
Dann schauen wir
am 13 Uhr
und
da wird es
genau auf 3000 Meter
einig sein.
Die Daten jetzt noch nicht
sehr viel mehr haben, sondern nur
3000 Meter mehr als
das Wind, die das angezeigt hat.
Auf Grundlegung sieht man,
okay, kommt starker Wind auf,
hier geht er einfach noch mal deutlich
weiter nach unten bei Windy,
äh, bei Metroparabol als bei Windy.
Dann schauen wir, was
sagt der Bernie.
Wir müssen auf Metaprognose gehen
und dann blenden wir mal
den Mieterschlag aus.
Schauen wir mal auf 1000 Meter
für morgen.
Und da hat es auch
21,24 mH
Wind an, also
im Prinzip sind sie sich
recht einig, das heißt
auch wieder, dass das
ziemlich sicher eintreffen
wird, oder je
mehr die Sie da hinziehen,
je höher ist die Trefferquote,
dass das auch passen wird,
13 Uhr, also
gleiches Thema.
Dann noch ein paar
Zimmerlehrer,
Einheit,
dann sehen wir, dass es auch
doch stärker
lebt,
also ordentlich
sicher ist für den Preis.
Wenn wir das Ganze dann
vergleichen mit
zuerst
mit dem Diagramm,
dann sehen wir, dass da
eben auch
das Diagramm noch bis
ja, irgendwann späte
Nachmittag, Abend, wenn man das
beim SAV anschaut, dann hat man
da noch eine bessere
zeitliche Skala, dann sieht man,
dass da das Ganze
morgen, jeden
Nachmittag trifft das ein,
da irgendwo
kommt dann die Front rein,
gleich an 18 Uhr,
und da fängt es ein, dass die ganze Zeit
da bis dann
vielleicht auch 8 Hektopascal,
hier ist es halt so, dass da
haben wir doch ein bisschen eine Unsicherheit
in der Prognose, also
wo dann auch was tatsächlich
unendlich gemessen wird, aber
es hat einen deutlichen
Programmspiel, bis am
Nachmittag hält es dann
irgendwo, und dann
macht man auch, weil es irgendwo
da kommt, dann die Front rein.
Ich denke, wenn man
so versucht, mit dem
direkten Vergleich,
vielleicht auch so aufgebaut,
alle drei nebeneinander,
kann man sich
für den jeweiligen Tag sehr,
sehr gut vorbereiten.
Eine grobe Prognose würde ich
also schon auch noch eine
Textprognose mit reinnehmen,
so mit der Schweiz
Textprognose lesen,
finde ich, gehört schon auch noch dazu,
hat man mal mit einem
nicht schnell,
ja, ersichtlich,
vielleicht kommt
Föhn auf, oder
es ist eh Tiefdruckwetter,
Tiefdruckbestimmend mit Niederschlag,
Fronten sind oft
gezwungen,
auch im Wetterbericht
integriert in der
Textprognose, und darum
ist es eigentlich auch immer noch
wichtig, dass das noch mit reingenommen
wird. Im Wetter ist es
auch so, ihr solltet schauen,
man kann da sehr viel
Zeit
verbrauchen,
oder benötigen, darum
muss man immer schauen, wenn man
schon mit einer groben
Ansicht sieht, ja,
Donnerstag, Freitag, Samstag,
ist es eh nichts, dann würde ich
da jetzt auch nicht zu sehr im Detail
meine Propose machen, wenn ich aber sehe,
hm, am Sonntag sieht es
immer gut aus, dann würde ich mir
den Sonntag wirklich genauer anschauen,
und das natürlich halt am Samstag,
auch sagt das nur, jetzt
den Sonntag hinzuschauen,
kann so kommen,
kann aber auch sein, dass es
definitiv
nicht zukommt, und darum
ist es halt eine rechte Spekulation,
aber natürlich,
für die eigene Planung schon mal
wichtig ist.
Die sind ja deutlich besser geworden.
Darum kann man da schon mal
ein bisschen in die Zukunft blicken.
Aber es ist halt doch noch
eine Frage,
ob die Daten mal aufgelistet werden.
Das ist ja nur so viel
möglich.
Aber bei dem,
kann man da
mit dem entsprechenden Modell
die Modelle einstellen.
Das würde ich mir mal so weit
stehen lassen.
Eigentlich von meiner Seite her
so weit
den Überblick geschaffen.
Einfach mal für Wind.
Dann würde ich
das Ganze hier
schnell stoppen.
Und nachher noch,
wer Lust hat, Wolken
und Niederschlag anschauen.
Wobei bei Wolken
würde ich tatsächlich
mit reinnehmen.
Auf dem Handy.
Die Animation.
Und vor allen Dingen
für den Niederschlag.
Gut.
Dazu schon mal irgendwelche
Fragen.
Wir müssen mal schauen,
ob wir das richtig einnehmen.
Ja, du, Dani, eine Frage.
Ja.
Respektive, ich habe gesehen,
die Station auf dem Grab
ist offline
seit gestern.
Ja.
Und auf dem Burner
sieht man auch nichts.
Man hat das irgendeinen Grund.
Ja.
Entweder ist die wieder abgebrochen
vom starken Wind, blockiert
oder
hat einen anderen technischen Hintergrund.
Aber ich kann es dir aktuell nicht sagen.
Okay.
Müsste man das jemandem mitteilen oder so?
Ja, es bringt nichts.
Nein, da muss man schauen gehen.
Die wird wahrscheinlich
vom starken Wind
wieder abgebrochen sein.
Das ist das Letzte.
Vermutlich.
Okay, danke.
Aber ja, falls jemand oben ist in Wiefahren,
wäre cool, wenn er da vorbei ist und man kündigt.
Okay, gut.
Dann haben wir jetzt noch eine Minute.
Dann kommt das Ganze da, weil es braucht wieder einen Moment zum Konvertieren und
tut dann nochmal eine neue Sitzung auf mit Wolken und Niederschlag.
Und dann würde ich sagen, am Ende noch weitere Fragen beantworten.
Vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit.
Vielen Dank.